bien sur votre plateau parce qu'on sait
que c'est une chaîne qui est regardé par
énormément de jeunes
pour faire lumière sur l'Insee aussi
sensibiliser les enfants c'est ça vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est un jour
férié donc il y aura beaucoup de
personnes devant la télé
le parrain c'est pas moi le pareil
d'accord c'est pas mal il est pas là il
y a justement
commencé au mois de septembre l'année
passée
c'est monté crescendo et puis c'était
des petites insultes des brimades et au
fur et à mesure de l'année
ça a commencé vraiment à s'aggraver
comment vous avez été mis au courant
très vite de de ça ce que c'est c'est
elle qui vous l'a dit ou bien ce que
vous l'avez su par d'autres élèves ou
est-ce que c'est les professeurs qui
vous l'ont dit NON NON donc nous on a
nous en parler d'accord elle vous l'a
dit elle nous en parler l'évoquer
beaucoup avec sa maman
elle vous a dit quoi il se passait quoi
au tout début c'était quoi on a vraiment
envie de comprendre et on a vraiment
envie que toutes les familles qui nous
regardent ce soir comprennent comment ça
peut commencer comment ça peut dégénérer
comment ça peut arriver un drame 6 on
l'a ce soir
c'est surtout pour que ça se reproduise
plus ils sont là pour vraiment aider des
familles qui ont de regarder ce soir et
des jeunes pour que ça se reproduise
plus c'est vraiment la démarche que vous
vouliez faire ce soir Merci à VOUS
d'ailleurs encore une fois et c'est vrai
qu'on veut on veut voir un petit peu
tout le cheminement c'est à dire qu'au
départ qu'est-ce qui se passait avec
avec l'Insee elle est en quelle classe
elle était en quatrième en quatrième
donc un moment elle rentre de l'école
elle vous dit quoi elle vous dit ça se
passe mal à l'école c'était des insultes
sur son physique vous avez vu au début
qu'il y avait des
des problèmes ou pas du tout que elle
avait changé ou bien
c'est donc elle vous a dit quoi vous
avez on m'insulte à l'école on m'insulte
à l'école
et se moquer tout en elle sur son
physique
des insultes vraiment c'était tout le
temps même tes grosses après je sais pas
si je peux dire les mots mais
au début c'était ça la ridiculiser aussi
tout le temps je faisais tout le temps
ridiculiser devant tout le monde
après bah c'est c'est monté de plus en
plus forcément moi j'ai été voir
plusieurs fois ces filles pour qu'ils
arrêtent donc c'était des filles de sa
classe des filles de 3e le troisième
donc les classes au dessus et qui
venaient quoi c'était quoi aux
interclasses quoi c'était au cours de
récré quand elle arrivait à l'école
devant le collège
c'est-à-dire qu'elle rentrait aussi le
soir ça continue et sur les réseaux en
plus c'est une résonance qui est plus
importante donc forcément il y a
d'autres gens qui se greffaient aussi
donc c'est c'est ça c'était elle voulait
dire elle vous a dit maman elle vous a
dit quoi au début on m'insulte j'ai plus
envie d'aller à l'école ou bien voilà je
qu'est-ce que je fais vous a demandé
conseil
faisait la forte en fait donc elle
disait qu'elle avait pas peur
quand elle recevait des messages sur les
réseaux sociaux à me les montrer elle
m'a envoyé des captures d'écran
directement donc je suis vraiment je
suivais tout donc je voyais vraiment
tout ce qui se passait et elle me
cachait vraiment rien
vous êtes rendu compte de la gravité de
de ce qui se passait ou pas du tout au
début comme vous disiez vous disiez elle
me dit tout elle me raconte tout elle
montre tout c'est qu'elle a un certain
recul et que voilà on échange ensemble
donc c'est et voilà c'est moins grave
que ce que si elle s'était repliée sur
elle-même parce que vous êtes dit ça moi
c'est ce que je me serais dit en fait
oui c'est ça oui parce que elle me
parlait tout ça je me suis dit c'est bon
elle souffre pas se repose sur moi en
fait comme il y avait un dialogue vous
êtes dit voilà elle se repose sur moi et
puis elle me tient au courant donc
forcément voilà elle est pas dans son
coin seul et et
elle vous en parlait tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
elle m'a envoyé je lui disais pas
répondre elle répondait pas mais où je
lui disais de les bloquer carrément mais
bon elle faisait des faux comptes donc
elle recommençait
ça
voilà si vous êtes la source ici c'est
très important parce que non seulement
on va parler le harcèlement à l'école
mais hors de l'école et sur les réseaux
sociaux et là je vous dis il y a
vraiment un manquement qui est
dramatique et qui est très grave moi
après une affaire comme ça que ça bouge
pas encore au niveau des autorités au
niveau de la gouvernance sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est inadmissible je suis
désolé je vous dis normalement il doit
avoir des modérateurs il doit avoir des
il savent faire plein de choses
effectivement des des des des des des
modérateurs qui puisse voir dès qu'il y
a des messages négatifs de harcèlement
direct ils sont directement effacés
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas ils
sont capables de tout faire avec la
technologie aujourd'hui ils sont
capables de faire plein de choses mais
ils sont surtout plus capables de faire
le mal que le bien donc aujourd'hui ça
c'est une admissible et que je vais vous
dire et qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
personnes qui ne s'en charge pas c'est
inadmissible parce que je vous dis bien
sûr qu'à l'école l'école c'est le
harcèlement à l'école on va en reparler
bien sûr qu'elle vivait de me montrer
difficiles mais avant quand les élèves
rentraient chez eux ils étaient avec
leurs familles ils entendaient plus
parler de ça c'est ça j'étais dans leur
cocon ils étaient avec vous ils étaient
bien le week-end aussi là le problème
c'est que c'est ça qui fait qu'il y a
des drames plus importants qu'avant mais
je vais vous dire ça dort ça bouge pas
il y a aucune noix qui est prononcée il
y a rien qui est fait si c'est
inadmissible excusez-moi moi quand je
vois vodka aujourd'hui vous êtes là
aujourd'hui pour que ça se reproduise
pas si les gens qui ont le pouvoir ne
bougent pas ça se reproduira et demain
on aura d'autres parents qui viendront
et qui nous diront la même chose on en a
eu on en aura encore mais j'en ai
entendu personne s'exprimer là-dessus
personne
s'exprime sur plein de choses ce sont
pas exprimés là-dessus sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut faire quelque chose il y
a une urgence je vous le dis c'est
vraiment c'est un fléau oui c'est un
fléau et aujourd'hui
Betty et François ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui ils viennent pour que ça se
reproduise plus mais eux ils font ce
qu'ils peuvent et ils vont nous raconter
l'histoire ils ont fait mais si en haut
ça bouge pas je vous le dis ils peuvent
faire ce qu'ils veulent il y aura encore
des drames donc elle rentre à la maison
ça continue sur les réseaux c'est ce que
vous nous disiez c'est ça
et donc je suis sûr que vous la voyez
elle était toute la journée sur ses
hôtels à regarder ce qui se disait sur
elle et harcèlement voilà c'est un et le
lendemain elle allait à l'école et ça
continue ça continue c'est ça ça
continue mais nous on la rassuré comme
on pouvait avec le mot c'est bien sûr on
est les parents ouverts
par rapport à certains parents ils sont
très fermés ils veulent peut-être pas
les enfants peut-être peur de pas
pouvoir évoquer certains
il y avait un dialogue voilà il y avait
un dialogue et je prenais beaucoup de
temps avec elle je passais des heures
dans sa chambre en discutait tout le
temps elle me disait tout mais c'est ça
c'est ça qui est je dis que c'est ça qui
est encore plus grave je trouve parce
qu'on entend souvent
des histoires ou l'enfant vraiment se
referme sur lui-même il en parle pas il
y a un moment il y a un drame qui se
passe et les parents sont au courant de
vous il y avait énormément de dialogues
je me dis elle vous en parler tous les
soirs et le drame est arrivé donc il
faut trouver des solutions qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé est-ce que vous avez essayé
d'aller voir à l'école ce qui se passait
d'aller voir ce jeune fille forcément
oui François alors
j'ai mon déclencheur ça a été au mois de
février
j'ai fait le ménage dans sa chambre j'ai
retourné son matelas pour mettre face
hiver
et c'est là qu'on a trouvé une lettre
une lettre de suicide d'accord
donc on a visé l'Académie d'accord
donc on a visé l'Académie on a
les services de police on a visé le
proviseur du collège
s'ensuit
une lettre la mamie l'Insee
dès qu'on a découvert la lettre à la
fille à courrier Monsieur Emmanuel
Macron
sans réponse
moi je veux dire ce qui me choque le
plus c'est qu'il y a pas de réponse du
proviseur je suis désolé mais ça on va
ça justement
on a reçu aucun courrier aucun appel du
proviseur de personnes
il y en a pas mal
quand on a demandé à la rencontre il
nous a rencontré deux fois une fois et
après c'est le CPU une fois et après
c'est le CP et la seule solution
et la seule réponse qui a pu nous donner
c'est il faut lui supprimer sur
téléphone il faut lui confisquer son
téléphone
chose que j'ai faite je l'ai je lui ai
présenté téléphone pendant 2 jours parce
que je me suis dit peut-être que c'est
une solution mais elle comprenait pas
elle me disait maman c'est pas moi qui a
fait du mal pourquoi c'est moi qui est
puni aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
exactement vous avez tout résumé et
celle qui l'a harcelé elles sont à
l'école actuellement
le collège des Rousseaux avant d'arriver
d'accord mais aujourd'hui elle continue
elles sont là-bas non mais elle continue
les menaces elle continue les de
d'insulter ma fille qu'elle est plus là
sur les réseaux
cette [__] je vais lui pisser sur sa
tombe je vais lui cramer sa tombe et ça
n'arrête pas
ça continue et donc les réseaux sociaux
il dit rien
la mort dans mes bras on découvre mais
dans quel monde on vit et là et et il
s'occupe de trucs que tout le monde se
fout alors que ça c'est vraiment il y a
une urgence incroyable et le proviseur
pas un mot faut savoir que le proviseur
c'est
une personne totalement méprisant
arrogante hôtel
je suis là je suis intervenu une fois
parce que
Betty il m'a dit qu'elle allait se faire
tabasser à la sortie du collège
ah oui que donc j'étais en personne
effectivement elle commençait à se faire
démolir
on a dû intervenir
elle est en train de se faire frapper à
la sortie par défaut à la sortie par des
filles ce groupe de filles toujours
c'était le jour du brevet blanc et
l'Insee elle était à l'école et elle
recevait des messages sur son téléphone
en disant qu'il attendait à la sortie
pour la frapper donc l'Insee elle m'a
envoyé des messages en me disant mais
moi j'ai pas j'avais pas mon téléphone
sur moi donc j'ai pas vu donc il y a
elle a été elle a été avertir le
proviseur le CPE de ça
et les gamines elles finissaient
normalement à 15h30 et l'Insee 16h30 ils
ont laissé l'Insee sortir se faire
tabasser au lieu de la mettre dans une
pièce et m'appeler pour la sécuriser en
fait c'est très grave excusez-moi si on
n'était pas intervenu je pense que ça
aurait vraiment ses cheveux on a dû la
tirer justement pour la pour la sauver
de ça il faut savoir aussi que tout le
personnel enseignant ainsi que le
directeur de l'établissement était
présent ils étaient juste à côté et
quand j'étais le voir parce que bien sûr
ça reste ta fille qui se fait frapper et
qu'il y a personne qui bouge je dis la
phrase je dis vous attendez quoi qu'elle
se suicide je lui dis je lui ai dit
cette fois et m'a regardé il m'a dit que
ce que vous voulez que je fasse monsieur
c'est en dehors de mon établissement
c'est ce qui m'a dit oh je suis outré
qui vous est même pas passé un coup de
fil après le on a fait une marche
blanche le mercredi on a fait cette
marche blanche la mamie a essayé de le
contacter et pareil nous a répondu qu'il
y avait pas de temps à nous consacrer
ah non mais c'est ah ouais c'est
regarde les images bien sûr on a tous
entendu parler même pas un mot rien ils
sont pas venus personne de
l'établissement rien du tout personne du
tout personne
et donc sur Tik Tok parce que je sais
que c'est au vu au-dessus de tout le
monde elle continue donc à insulter
votre fille mais même sa meilleure amie
et là elles sont en train de s'en
prendre sur sa meilleure amie en fait en
disant que si il y a encore des vidéos
qui tournaient sur Tik Tok il y a la
voir des représailles du coup la
meilleure amie de ma fille elle ose même
plus elle à l'école mais c'est pas un
homme
mis en examen pour harcèlement scolaire
et on conduit au suicide c'est ça les
quatre mineurs et un adulte pour menaces
de mort alors ça j'ai été surprise
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un adulte aussi
et harcelait et vous menacez c'est ça ma
fille c'est ma fille plusieurs c'est une
mère de d'une des filles qui a accès
d'une des harceleuse
alors ça c'est l'enquête judiciaire il y
a une enquête administrative mais ce qui
est incroyable dans l'histoire c'est que
vous avez prévenu tout le monde Insee
vous a parlé tout le monde a été prévenu
et là on a une pauvre réaction du
directeur académique qui reconnaît à
demi-mot une responsabilité collective
ça veut rien dire c'est-à-dire qu'il y
ait aucun soutien les CP la direction
psychologue infirmière tout le monde a
été avisé par vous ou par Lindsay
personne n'a rien fait et une petite
précision aussi l'Insee est allé voir le
proviseur elle lui avait dit Monsieur il
continue
un petit peu un petit peu plus tard elle
continue j'en ai marre je veux vraiment
arrêter et lui a dit de toute façon tout
est noté
bah ça ça reste entre nous tu ne dis
rien à personne alors
je suis harcèlement à continuer
continuer continuer elle avait déjà
écrit une lettre d'adieu il y a quelques
mois ce qu'on avait dit et votre FIAD
décidé de mettre fin à ses jours le
vendredi 12 mai c'est ça
mais sur la lettre d'adieu elle
dit bien qu'elle a demandé de l'aide au
directeur et que il tenait avec les
harceleuses et que c'était qui les
dépend il voulait pas l'aider il voulait
pas l'écouter
c'est vous qui l'avez trouvé c'est qui
c'est au mois de février c'est
votre fille au moment du drame c'est
c'était le 12 mai qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé le matin vous avez senti déjà
qu'il y avait un le matin non elle a
pris son déjeuner elle est partie à
l'école parce qu'en fait je voulais vous
dire aussi que le la veille donc le
jeudi 11 l'Insee a fait un malaise à
l'école donc j'étais appelé par le CPE
je suis allée au collège et quand je
suis allée il y avait les pompiers donc
elle avait fait un malaise donc je suis
allée directement à l'hôpital donc c'est
bien écrit dessus que le malaise en fait
elle en cours de récréation elle voyait
des visages des regards portés sur elle
et conclusion c'est
malaise crise d'angoisse du harcèlement
donc la veille
et donc le lendemain qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le lendemain
Lindsay s'est réveillé bon elle s'est
préparée comme d'habitude et
elle a pris son déjeuner et puis elle me
dit bon ben à un moment je vais déjeuner
et puis bon elle prend son déjeuner pour
aller à l'école et puis elle est partie
elle a mangé à la cantine et puis
à 17h elle est rentrée elle était
normale 17h30 elle est rentrée elle
était normale elle a pris son goûter et
elle faisait ses devoirs on a fait les
devoirs ensemble parce qu'elle avait des
verbes irréguliers d'accord en anglais
apprendre donc vous l'avez aidé là
dessus tout apprendre pour le lundi donc
on a digite à quatre pattes ça va aller
je dis on va le faire ensemble
tranquillement
du lendemain nous elle nous a dit qui
c'est qui nous ramène demain
s'intéresser mais en fait à 17h10 elle
avait envoyé déjà un message à sa copine
en disant que je ne serai pas là
on comprend pas parce que c'est vous qui
avez découvert
elle était je comprends pas et même ses
camarades de classe de ses copines nous
disait on l'a jamais vu aussi souriante
qu'aujourd'hui
donc on sait pas peut-être qu'elle a
reçu quelque chose entre temps on est
dans l'attente
on a totalement été lâché dans cette
histoire totalement et pour la pourtant
le maire devant la Louviers
il était même pas au courant il le
savait pas ils l'ont même pas tenu au
courant nous il s'est présenté à nous
gêné il le savait même pas non mais
c'est inadmissible ce qui s'est passé au
niveau de l'établissement et
je vous dis au niveau des autres parents
des c'est incroyable je vous dis là là
je vois tous les gens disent c'est
incroyable cette histoire et
après ce drame aucun coup de fil rien du
tout de ses professeurs
rien du tout
aucun professeur la marche
l'Institut les deux astuces de nos
garçons qui sont venus
4 ans
comment ils vont aujourd'hui les deux
petits frères c'est dur vous savez
le matin quand on se réveille
c'est pas évident d'expliquer à son
petit frère
elle était très proche du dire c'est
parce qu'il faut trouver les mots aussi
et puis nous attends
pas évident le plus grand il est très
fort il est très très fort à les cieux
qui comprend
comprend mais le petit c'est très très
dur le petit
bon bah c'est l'Insee c'est son étoile
il comprend pas quoi il nous dit bon ben
moi aussi je vais aller au ciel pourquoi
moi j'ai pas le droit d'y aller pour
aller voir l'Insee donc c'est dur parce
qu'il faut savoir parler à l'enfant
c'est pour ça que les enfants vont être
suivis
nous aussi d'ailleurs
pour vous bien sûr mais aussi que vous
avez été complètement lâché cette
histoire complètement on a été lâché on
n'a pas été soutenu je pense
qu'aujourd'hui s'ils ont fait leur
travail si ils nous ont aidé je pense
que l'INSEE elle sera encore en vie
aujourd'hui parce que pour moi c'est pas
ma fille c'est tu es c'est eux qui ont
tué ma fille ils l'ont poussé à faire ça
il y a aussi tout de même les parents de
ces jeunes filles
le proviseur il a une pas une grosse
part de responsable
et les parents doivent dire aux enfants
attention tu rien à [__] le bordel ça
va nous créer des problèmes et cette
mère t'a envoyé les textos j'espère que
elle on va s'occuper d'elle parce que
elle on peut s'occuper d'elle les
enfants de 12-13 ans qui font les cons
machin et ça c'est ça doit changer
mais le proviseur en premier c'était à
lui de stopper ça c'est à lui de stopper
ça veut dire on est c'est pas dans mon
établissement et alors on est tellement
tellement triste pour vous on est on est
énervé on dit aussi parce que on se dit
c'est pas possible qu'il y a rien qui a
été fait et je le vois tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent en
direct ce soir se disent c'est
inadmissible c'est on a on a du mal à y
croire aux gens on a du mal à y croire
que personne n'est rien fait je voudrais
vous remercier d'avoir été là ce soir
parce que c'est très important votre
témoignage et j'espère que ça va faire
bouger les choses et on va essayer de
faire bouger les choses même parce que
vous avez dit un truc très important
aussi c'est que ça meilleur ami est
harceler actuellement on dirait pas qui
arrive un deuxième princesse je voulais
vous remercier d'avoir été là soit parce
que pour vous il a fallu beaucoup de
courage et je peux vous dire même
on sait pas comment vous faites vous
regardez autant mettre en forme et
autant être vous êtes vraiment vous êtes
impeccable voilà je voulais vous le dire
c'est vrai que c'est une notion que vous
avez donné encore ce soir on espère que
voilà je vous dis que vous avez dit vous
espérez juste que ça se reproduise pas
c'est pour ça que vous êtes venu ce soir
merci à vous deux merci